hello there this is the heavy spoiler
show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who loves
to tango when it comes to django
and this video are breaking down the bad
batch episode 5.
the star wars show is now halfway
through its first season
and in this video we're going to be
discussing the plot easter eggs
hidden details and things that you might
have missed the series so far has been a
real trip through the galaxy
there's actually a lot of similarities
to the mandalorian
not only has omega ended up being
protected by some road weary ragtag
warriors
but she now also has a bounty on her
head just like grogu
that has made it so the group not only
have the empire after them
but also bounty hunters last week saw
the arrival of fennik shand
who you will probably know from the
aforementioned show
she really made a big entrance and ming
naowen's performance has been one of the
strongest in the series thus far
throughout the show there's also been
several characters rubbing their heads
including rekka at several points many
have theorized that this means his chip
is now
active and we will be discussing that
theory further into the video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into star wars the
bad batch episode 5.
okay so the episode titled rampage is a
reference to a rancor
going on well a rampage kind of wish
they had smarter titles so i could sound
intelligent but luckily enough my
british accent helps to provide that
anyway
so it's all good now we cut once more to
the ship
traveling through hyperspace this is
something that has been present in three
out of the five episodes
and i quite like how every entry just
feels like a brand new adventure as the
crew head to another destination
omega is given a comms device and these
have come in a range of formats
throughout the star wars canon
we can see the c1 on the right here and
on the left is the comlink
which i'm not kidding was actually made
from a gillette woman's razor
now omega getting one of these seems
like the team's doing a really nice
thing for her
but going off last week it's actually
because they just want to keep her safe
and stop her going off with bounty
hunters we learned that it belonged to
crosshair
and after taking what i think was his
room she's now taking his stuff too
also i love how we can catch rekka doing
barbell squats
with the gunk droid behind here in star
wars it's been a long running joke that
no one actually knows what a gong droid
does
and this one seems to have turned into
his personal weight set
as we saw him doing dumbbell curls with
it earlier in the season
we discover that they're going to old
mantel home of the black sun
who have appeared in the star wars
expanded universe at several points
in shadows of the empire the group was
headed up by prince geisel
whose name i'm probably pronouncing
wrong but i was six when i played that
game
and that's how i read it and it's it's
not changed in my head
now the organization appeared in several
clone wars episodes
and also allied themselves with darth
maul but unfortunately they're not in
this entry
instead the group go to meet a jedi
informant called sid
and this might be not the final fantasy
as almost every game in the franchise
featured a character called that now
they go to sids bar and shout out simone
berman on twitter for pointing out that
we can see a loth cat
as well as a hammerhead alien in the
location sid was allied with the jedi
and she does the old yoda trick of
denying who she is when they initially
meet her
but omega sees through the disguise
straight away we've long theorized that
she's force sensitive
and is the culmination of the cloner's
work omega typically means the end
and creating a force-sensitive clone
would be the final stage of the
cameron's work
now i love how you can theorize things
like this but also just see her as being
far more intelligent than the other
clones
and sid takes the batch into her office
in the room we not only see the helmet
of a clone trooper
but also a mandalorian one and the hide
of a banter draped over her chair
simon also spotted what might have been
a mud horn horn on her desk
but let us know below if you think it's
anything else sid says that since the
death of the jedi her service demands
have declined
and it shows how the empire has affected
pretty much every aspect of society
the jedi were of course the keepers of
peace in the galaxy
but since they were pretty much all
wiped out everything connected to them
has to stabilize too
the group bring up fenik shan and sid
says she'll find out who hired her
in exchange for them doing a job for her
i love how she says
are you fresh out the tube which is of
course the insult that you'd use on
clones
instead of saying were you born
yesterday this is also the first time
that they're referred to as mercenaries
instead of soldiers echo questions it
but it quickly becomes apparent that
it's the truth
and it lets them know they'll never be
accepted into the army again
and must find a way to make their way
throughout the galaxy
sid also calls omega the brains of the
operation
which could be a nod to when dash render
called chewbacca
when referring to how stupid han was in
shadows of the empire
sid sends them to rescue a child named
muchi who was taken
by zygerian slavers you might recognize
the zeigerians from the clone wars and
in star wars law these feline humanoids
built an entire empire off of the back
of slaves
anakin ended up working alongside one at
one point and during that he rode on the
back of a brezzack
one of which appears in this episode now
the jedi were enemies of the zaigerian
because they used slaves
however the clone troopers themselves
were very much slaves too
so it shows the hypocrisy that existed
within them
anyway the group head off like jango
fett and we see rekka
rubbing his once more this is something
that he's done throughout the series
and we also saw crosshair doing it too
he of course is now under the control of
the empire
and ready to do their bidding i do feel
that wrecker's chip
may have activated too as they've
brought a lot of attention to it
he once more hits his head in this
episode and either it's now in full
effect
or is completely destroyed and it shows
that they can disable crosshairs
by just smacking him in the head hard
enough a wrecker could potentially now
be a sleeper agent amongst their ranks
and be totally unaware of exactly what's
going on the motions of robbing have
been carried across
in several characters i do think that it
would be a big twist
if all of a sudden the empire activated
him omega plays with the dollar she got
in the last episode
and this was a nod to the one that jyn
erso had in rogue one
she makes some alterations to it to make
it more like the bad batch
which is a nice little bit of character
development to show how much she admires
them
at the base the batch believe that
moochie is one of the fellaine prisoners
and they sneak into their hideout chaizo
was actually part of the felline
which is a nice little call back to
shadows of the empire and potentially
we could be seeing his origin story here
if they decide to wreck on it
now after the batch are caught it's up
to omega to bust them out
the clones are called the skug by the
zygerians and this is actually an
insult that they've used at several
points in star wars canon
they mention returning to cadavo to get
back what was taken from them
and this is a reference to their loss at
the battle of cadavo
season 4 episode 13 of the clone wars
was called escape from cadavo
and it revolved around obi-wan and the
clone troopers almost being enslaved by
the zygerians
before they managed to escape now it's
not too long before we discover that
moochie is actually a rancor
and at one point we see sid talking to a
hologram in her teas
this is bib fortuna and the rancor is
for jabba's collection
now whilst you may assume that this is
the rancor we see in return of the jedi
we learn in the expanded law that that's
called patisser
so muchi could potentially be its mother
or again it might be a retcon
omega frees moochie and it goes wild
busting up most of the slavers
when the speeders chase after it we can
also hear the same sound effects that
were used on them in return of the jedi
the bad batch realized that if they
don't save much they won't be able to
gain the intel
and thus they defeat the brezzack and
zaigerian leader
however the rancor isn't as easy and
it's up to wrecker to take it down
he further bangs his head in the
conflict and if this is just all leading
to nothing
then i'm gonna be so so angry you better
not mephisto me again
now the rancor is given to bib and he
heads off back to jabba's palace
we know from the expanded law that one
died in a crash
whilst being escorted to the location
but it did go on to have an offspring
again whether this is retconned or not
we don't know
but i like that there's at least some
tied to it now sid reveals that shan
is working on direct commission and says
that she contacted people in the guild
the guild of course was what the
mandalorian operated under in the show
and who knows we might even see grief
kaga now it is possible that she's been
hired by boba fett
and this would explain why she's so
loyal to him after the events of attack
of the clones
he went on to form his own group of
bounty hunters and we know that the
mandalorian ends with him taking over
bib's operation
and hey it's like poetry they rhyme now
as for my thoughts on the series
so far i think the first five episodes
have been really solid
whilst on the whole i wouldn't say that
they're completely knocking
out of the park each and every time i do
like the very character-driven narrative
that the show has been leading with
i would say that this is more of a drama
that wrestles with the themes of
conformity
versus independence than it does with
all our action
i don't think it's too much of a stretch
to say that the empire are very much a
metaphor for the nazis
and one of the periods in history that i
was highly fascinated with at school in
uni
was their rise to power clearly they
came in and took over
and the general population in germany
conformed to their ideas
however there were those that resisted
and i view the bad batches fitting that
mold
whilst the other soldiers sort of
represent the rest of the population
we've even had characters fleeing
planets taken over by the imperials
and people who could see the way that
things were going in germany two took a
similar action
though i might be reaching with this
whole metaphor i appreciate that the
show sparks these kinds of things in my
brain
as i think they're really interesting
conversations to have
and what the show also does well is that
you can probably enjoy it on its surface
and not go looking for any of those
illusions and still have a good time
this is also interesting because it's in
a time period in star wars lore that we
haven't really seen before
therefore the show exploring this does
also help to make it important in star
wars history
rather than it's simply being relegated
to something that's run of the mill
as i've been saying we are at the
halfway point now and it's developing
really well
and connecting to the grander universe
in a cohesive manner
i feel like the prequels are regarded
much higher now than when they were
first released because of shows like the
clone wars
which helped to flesh out the characters
and story bad batch is doing the same
and though it's taking its time to get
fully going i'm still having fun with
the ride
so far my interest level is probably at
about a seven
but i know there's a varied amount of
opinions on it now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the show so far
and of course this episode too comment
below and let me know and as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
army of the dead which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the unanswered questions
on the film and have given our theories
on them
as well as what zack snyder has said so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you're confused over the movie
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i mean paul
i'll see you next time take care peace